te será un alivio del confinamiento en
tres pasos el primero comienza este
sábado por la mañana será posible
moverse en un área de 20 kilómetros
alrededor de su casa durante tres horas
se permitirán actividades extraescolares
al aire libre y los servicios religiosos
se podrán celebrar de nuevo dentro del
estricto límite de 30 personas cuando
finalmente todos los comercios podrán
reabrir los servicios a domicilio se
reanudarán pero bajo un estricto
protocolo de salud otro college state
street estas tiendas deberán estar
cerradas a más tardar a las nueve de la
noche para comenzar la segunda etapa el
martes 15 de diciembre el cierre podría
ser levantado y en su lugar un 'toque de
queda' de nueve de la noche a siete de
la mañana excepto para las fiestas de
nochebuena y nochevieja aunque no
podemos volver a movernos sin
autorización
incluso entre regiones para descansar y
encontrarnos de nuevo sí pero llamó su
sentido de la responsabilidad no será
una fiesta de navidad como las otras
acusaciones de sacamos de 9 con minuto
la cultura también debería volver a la
vida
de los franceses con la reapertura de
cines teatro y museos
finalmente el 20 de enero se supone que
marca la última etapa de desconfía
miento con la reapertura de restaurantes
y gimnasios reanudar las clases
totalmente en la escuela secundaria y
luego en las universidades y un toque de
queda más leve de 10 de la noche a 7 de
la mañana
alrededor del 20 de enero podremos tomar
si es posible nuevas decisiones de
apertura si el número de contagios se
mantiene por debajo de cinco mil diarios
en 2014 hasta esta fecha por lo tanto
las reuniones siguen estando prohibidas
también los eventos festivos parques de
atracciones y estaciones de esquí
emanuel manjón cuenta con una reapertura
a mediados de enero si no aparece una
nueva ola